oh yeah she's been everywhere man let's
just go ahead and rename this month
febrianna welcome everybody to
Entertainment Tonight you know first
there was the surprise pregnancy reveal
during halftime and now this Miss
fenty's fam we see you ASAP and baby on
the cover of British phone shame right
like a diamond this cover photo on the
beach was taken last December so no sign
of that internet breaking Super Bowl
bump Rihanna telling her baby boy quote
you are giving poses
you know it really feels Like A lot's
happening all at once but now
nine-month-old's name the British Vogue
reporter notes Rihanna ASAP Rocky and
their teams are so consistent in calling
him baby in my presence I half wonder if
his name might actually be baby the
interview actually took place 36 hours
after the Golden Globes Rihanna reveals
the birth was beautiful and they did not
have a nanny when they left the hospital
quote we came home cold turkey had no
one you're like they trusted us to come
home with this baby we're just going
home motherhood
Oscars Super Bowl I'm still pinching
myself really I'm grateful
as for riri's secret weapon for getting
back to work on the Super Bowl stage
[Music]
that's Rihanna's choreographer Paris
Goble who posted this behind the scenes
footage from the rehearsals as her
standing
next with Rihanna for the Super Bowl
freeze you know she just kind of breaks
through the rules so it's like every
time I work with her it's like you don't
know what to expect
Yelp like revealing a pregnancy and
today ET spoke with two of riri's backup
dancers who gave us behind the scenes
secrets about how she kept it hidden
during rehearsals
[Music]
she put a huge big blue fur coat little
did we know she was covering up her
pregnancy we just thought like oh that's
wrong with smashy dresses it was super
cold so her wearing coats and sweats
underneath was not suspicious at all we
were all confused watching it during the
real thing and was showing her stomach
she wore the same outfit for one of the
dress rehearsals but it was zippered up
she hid it very very well
foreign